et pour en parler ce soir jérôme
rodriguez gilet jaune et gilles casanova
spécialiste en communication bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france yo ma le disais en
atteint des records comparable
d'ailleurs à ce qui avait lancé la crise
et gilet jaune en 2018 jérôme rodriguez
qu'est ce que vous attendez du premier
ministre ce soir si tenté que vous en
attendez quelque chose
moi je crois que la preuve est faite que
naples à l'internement
on a perdu malheureusement jérôme
rodriguez qui n'a pas réussi à atteindre
pour la petite histoire ce plateau pour
cause de de bouchons parisiens a
malheureusement gilles casanova y joue
gros ce soir le rôle le premier ministre
les français attendent beaucoup
évidemment de ces annonces y ait une
vraie crispation autour de ce thème
alors nous sommes en période électorale
comme vous l'avez noté la baisse de la
fiscalité comme l'a fait remarquer le
ministre des finances ce serait une
baisse de la fiscalité pour un certain
temps alors que le chèque le chèque on
me donne jusqu'au deuxième tour après le
deuxième tour
le déluge peut arriver
l'idée c'est d'empêcher avant le
deuxième tour une fronde comme on a eu
celle des gilet jaune
il faut se souvenir d'une part que le
prix de l'essence a déjà été plus cher
dans ce pays qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
en revanche ce n'est pas le cas du prix
du gazole et on sait que le diesel et
puis largement utilisé par les
catégories populaires et des véhicules
qu'elle utilise que par les plus les
mieux dotées économiquement qui
utilisent des véhicules à essence et
souvent même cylindrée plus élevé donc
l'idée c'est d'essayer de calmer le jeu
avec les catégories populaires le
problème c'est tout de même que ça va
coûter cher et que si c'est une usine à
gaz
les personnes qui en seraient
bénéficiaires ne vont pas en bénéficier
parce que c'est trop complexe et elles
finiront par descendre dans la rue donc
c'est une équation délicate mais qui
s'arrête au deuxième tour car après le
deuxième tour il n'y a plus aucune
garantie d'aucune forme dead face à
cette flambée des prix de l'énergie et
qui sera redoublée d'une autre flambée
puisque l'union européenne s'engage à la
manière allemande dans la transition
énergétique
plutôt contre le nucléaire ce qui permet
à la france d'avoir à prix de
l'électricité malgré les augmentations
tellement plus bas qu'en allemand n'y
est bien comme on s'engage dans cette
logique là les autres énergies vont
augmenter et donc il y a là un problème
qui n'est que le début du fils que l'on
tire d'un pull-over qui va ce trick
détricoter très vite ça veut dire c'est
que casanova si on vous suit bien que ce
soir au mieux jean castex colmate les
brèches et pouf pour le moment les
mécontents
oui le but c'est simplement d'éviter un
trop gros mécontentement avant
l'élection puisque nous savons que nous
avons un gouvernement en campagne pour
le président qui se bat pour son
renouvellement
donc là on est dans une situation où
tout ce qui y est vision à long terme
est placé sous le bas de la pile des
dossiers sur le bureau et le premier
dossier c'est le renouvellement du
mandat du président et la tentative
qu'il va faire en ce sens et créer les
meilleures conditions pour cela tout le
reste peut être considérée comme annexe
pour un gouvernement dont le président
se représente dans les dernières
semaines alors
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que à priori
c'est l'option de chèques qui va être
privilégié je me propose des contes et
pierre chasserait ans qui représentent
40 millions d'automobilistes qui a
exprimé justement son mécontentement
quant à ce cher qu'en tout cas lui était
pour une baisse des taxes écoutez je
regarde l'échiquier politique m'aperçois
qu'à droite on est favorable à la baisse
des taxes michel barnier vient
d'annoncer je m'aperçois avec anne
hidalgo a été la première à parler de la
baisse des taxes donc non il ya
unanimité si on prend du côté de la
droite à la droite de la droite du côté
d'eric zemmour de marine le pen on est
favorable à la baisse des taxes non non
en fait y est une seule personne en
france qui est défavorable à la baisse
des taxes et les écologistes mais les
écologistes c'est qui
ces personnes moi j'ai l'impression que
les verts ils sont surtout très gris
quand ma main et quand il quand il
s'agit de chercher des arguments le donc
ça c'est une constante non non ce qu'il
faut maintenant c'est passé à l'action
arrêté un petit peu et se dire que quand
on est président de la république on est
élu par les français aujourd'hui on
pensait qu'ils ont portés manuel macron
à la tête de ce pays ont souhaité
souhaite une baisse des taxes sur le
carburant dont tacle c'est un braquage
l'entente % de taxes comment peut-on
encore accepté de neubourg qu'un produit
soit taxée à hauteur de 60% et
l'argument écologique faut arrêter faut
arrêter commençons à faire aux
politiques les français avant de se paie
quand même d'une minorité de marginaux
qui aujourd'hui plombe le pays la
bobologie c'est le cancer de la france
pierre chasserait très remonté hier soir
en direct sur ce bateau là on est ravis
d'accueillir c'est la magie du direct
jérôme rodriguez qui est apparue de sa
voiture dans les bouchons parisiens à ce
plateau est ravi que vous ayez réussi à
l'atteindre en tout cas jérôme rodriguez
je vous demandais quand on a été
interrompue par par la connexion voilà
on entend pierre chasserait nous dire
voilà moi j'étais en tout cas pour la
baisse des taxes c'est pas forcément ce
qu'on attend de la part du premier
ministre soit on va voir ce qui va nous
dire vous vous en attendez quelque chose
du premier ministre ce soir et ses huit
mois je pense que mon lit pour mettre du
concret d'accord aujourd'hui on est sur
une moyenne de 22% d'augmentation a aidé
moins d'un sur le sur les produits
carburant tout tous carburants confondus
ce qui représente sur un plein de 50
litres par semaine 15 euros de plus à la
semaine ce qui représente 780 euros à la
fin de l'année est ce qu'un français qui
gagnent en moyenne 300 euros par mois
avaient prévu de débourser 780 euros de
plus sur son budget initial je vous
passe le fioul ou on est à 400 euros de
plus en deux mois on est passé de 600 à
1000 euros les mille mètres cubes
fallait 1000 livres pardon voyez ce que
je veux dire ça c'est du concret dans la
poche est ce qu'aujourd'hui si monsieur
castex propose un chèque qui sera à la
hauteur de 780 euros est ce que
l'ensemble des travailleurs pour
aujourd'hui en france qui font vivre la
france seront bénéficiaires de ce chèque
c'est ça la vraie question parce
qu'aujourd'hui si on le chèque énergie
est une mesure et sur les 7 milliards
rapporté à l'état via la hausse du prix
du gaz où on va redistribuer seulement
10% aux plus modestes c'est à dire ceux
qui déclarent moins de onze mille euros
de d'impôts par an l'ensemble des
français aujourd'hui ne sont pas
concernés par ces aides de l'état et
c'est ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des gilet jaune l'ensemble
des citoyens en colère et des
travailleurs de france à voir aussi un
peu demain parce que fo a rappelé la
voiture en même ces jours-là au travail
j'ai le casanova ce que me dit jérôme
rodriguez c'est que voilà il ya ce
risque de mesurettes annoncées ce soir
par le premier ministre certains disent
le chèque c'est une mesure juste parce
qu'ils touchent les moins favorisés mais
enfin voilà il ya les classes moyennes
aussi qu'ils prennent la voiture qui
aurait bien besoin j'ai envie gazon a
fait l'addition
de cette addition salée pour pour les
ménages à ce que quoi qu'il arrive ça
risque d'être forcément une mauvaise
mesure et a fortiori ceux chaque mais il
faut comprendre que la difficulté d'un
gouvernement en campagne électorale
c'est de ne pas décourager la petite
partie de l'opinion qui le suit avec
intensité depuis un certain temps il y à
entre 10 et 12% des français qui sont en
plein accord avec le gouvernement avec
emmanuel macron qui lui ont donné cette
majorité parlementaire qui
ne sont pas allés voter aux régionales
ou municipales mais qui forment disons
la base sociale et cette base sociale
elle est extrêmement sensible à tous les
discours qui touche les couches
supérieures
le ce qu'on appelait traditionnellement
la petite bourgeoisie urbaine c'est à
dire le discours écologiste le discours
écologiste domine culturellement ces
catégories qui apportent leurs suffrages
de manière décisive à emmanuel macron et
à ses amis donc baisser les taxes c'est
aller à l'encontre de ce pied vraiment
un le choeur religieux de ceux de ce
groupe et donc il est très difficile de
baisser les taxes sur les carburants
fossiles sans risquer de perdre la
significativement un nombre de voix dont
vous voyez que l'affairé c'est très bien
expliqué en 100 kg de casanova on vous
remercie jérôme rodrigues est empreint
de sinistres donc on prend des décisions
alors évidemment on fait mine d'être
étonné enfin là quand même c'est une
catégorie de personnes une poignée
personne n'est pas dans l'intérêt de
tous les français c'est ce que c'est ce
que vous pensez en tout cas sans jouer
sur les mots prix du gaz il faudrait
éviter de faire comme on a l'habitude de
faire un front sidéré usine à gaz quoi
aujourd'hui on est capable si vous
voulez il ya un an de débloquer 240
milliards pour venir en aide à ceux qui
en avaient besoin je le remets pas en
cause et aujourd'hui quand les français
sont dans le besoin on nous dit que
c'est pas possible on nous sort tout un
tas de prétextes mais selon fiscale
le premier ministre a lancé se
rendront le blocage des prix du gaz sur
toute l'année 2022 voici la première
annonce de la soirée est ce que c'est
une satisfaisante qu'ils ont été bloqués
à plus de 57% et qui font des rentrées
d'argent que l'état n'avait pas prévu je
dirais que c'est tout bonus pour lui
donc a donné que cette somme d'argent
qu'ils qu'il récupère à défaut de le
mettre peut-être de mettre du tout
l'entièreté dans les positions
écologique de peut-être aussi de le
mettre dans la poche des français qui
aujourd'hui je subis cette économie de
plein fouet et je tiens à rappeler que
ceux qui sont les premiers tributaire de
ces hausses de prix sont les français de
première cordée ceux qui ont déjà
souffert depuis deux ans ne serait-ce
que face au co vite pour tenir les rangs
pour tenir leur travail et pour aller où
s'ils se rendent au travail
aujourd'hui évidemment la question que
tout le monde doit vous posez
et cochrane en premier lieu le
gouvernement cette reprise du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune aujourd'hui quel est
l'état d'esprit dans vos rangs en étant
ces mesures de manière faible pour
courage et ronan alors déjà je le répète
cette ce prix fixe cette particule
reprise reviennent retour les gilet
jaune ça n'existe pas ou vous êtes bien
passé rt pour nos livres fréquemment
depuis deux ans qu'on en est au 150e mac
os 10 à 6,4 à gouvernement vous êtes la
meilleure selon nos confrères d'europe 1
le service central de renseignement
étaient mobilisés pour surveiller
d'éventuels reprise du mouvement des
déchets dangereux je suis je suis assez
bien placé pour savoir qu'on est
surveillé principalement ma personne en
tous les cas quand je me pointe si on
parlait ou autres lieux lieu en france
la crainte elle est là pourquoi ils ont
peur parce qu'ils sont dans l'incapacité
aujourd'hui pouvoir répondre aux
français à défaut d'avoir peur aux
français à stallone ou autour d'une
table et si on débattre et si l'on
d'écouter les français qui eux ont des
propositions à faire pour améliorer leur
quotidien parce que force est de
constater que les politiques et le
gouvernement aujourd'hui sont hors sol
ils sont incapables d'apporter une
réponse à l'ensemble des citoyens en
colère pire que ça il nous fonder des
des lois liberticides qui empêche
d'autant plus le lien social et les
français de pouvoir communiquer et
peut-être fait remonter l'information de
ce mal-être aujourd'hui dans ce pays il
est important que qu'on puisse installer
un débat que d'installer un climat de
peur parce que c'est ce qui se joue
depuis deux ans de d'une part et d'autre
moi je suis pas là pour faire peur je
suis là pour discuter les gilets jaunes
ont des propositions à faire on a des
revendications à mettre en place a
proposé il serait grand temps de les
écouter parce que ce sont aussi eux qui
qui qui qui construisent la france et
pas que parce que il n'ya pas que les
filets jaunes en france bien entendu
alors j'en sois évidemment en direct le
fil des des annonces de gentes dames ont
pris la décision d'une indemnité
inflation de 100 euros qui sera versée
sans voir un pas deux cents 200 euros
qui sera versée aux français qui gagnent
moins de 2000 euros net par mois j'ai
casanova
décision d'une indemnité inflation 100
euros qui sera versée c'est une
indemnité donc on en rira les 780 euros
de budget d'augmentation du budget sur
les carburants la fin de l'année les 680
euros donc on n'y est pas
oui ça va être encore une usine à gaz
ont tiré un des documents et avoir fait
le métier d'administrateur et sert à
remplir des documents pour pouvoir
bénéficier de cette somme donc voilà on
y est pas quoi qu'il arrive on est
encore en train de nous enfumer et les
français continueront ne pas être
content et là je pense que oui ils
peuvent continuer d'avoir peur parce que
la colère manifestement il ya moins de
personnes dans la rue sans faire le jeu
de mots mais quoi qu'il arrive la colère
est bien présente et si vous voulez à
défaut de
celle ci celle ci explose bac on essaye
de mettre en place des choses justement
pour éviter ce genre de problème j'ai le
cas ça va quand on vous écoute et à la
fois les annonces de jean castex et
jérôme rodez est ce qu'il nous dit voilà
c'est pas parce que les jets les gens ne
sont pas dans la rue qui a pas de colère
elle est bien là c'est une colère que
risque qui risque fort emmanuel macron
de se retrouver dans les urnes en 2022
or il ya deux aspects le premier aspect
c'est que depuis 50 ans toutes sortes de
gouvernements de toutes sortes de
couleurs on pensait que donner de
l'argent avant l'élection allait faire
voter pour leur champion alors c'est en
général moins cynique que cette fois ci
mais il ya toujours quelque chose de ce
genre là ça n'a jamais fonctionné jamais
on peut donner de l'argent les lecteurs
avant l'élection il comprend bien que on
lui reprendra après donc ça ça ne marche
pas le deuxième aspect c'est celui-là
colère le problème de
faible mobilisation des gilet jaune
qu'il est lié au fait que lorsque le
mouvement a démarré il y avait une
certaine innocence sur ces ronds points
il y avait des personnes qui voulait
s'adresser au gouvernement en disant le
président le gouvernement ne comprennent
pas qu'il y a un malaise et il ne nous
entendent pas on va leur parler il va
comprendre ils vont prendre des mesures
ils savent maintenant que les mesures
qui ont été prises sont essentiellement
des mesures de répression à leur égard
et que ce n'est pas qu'on les entend pas
c'est qu'on a décidé de s'affronter à
eux sur le fond parce que c'est les
choix politiques que fait un
gouvernement que fait un président donc
voyant cela beaucoup de gens comprennent
bien que descendre dans la rue
aujourd'hui ça ne va pas
permettre d'obtenir une satisfaction
parce que c'est le premier gouvernement
depuis une cinquantaine d'années qui ne
négocient pas qui a très peu réagi par
rapport à des mobilisations et des
manifestations il n'a aucun parti
politique derrière dont il veut sauver
les élus je vous rappelle qu'il fait 2,2
pour cent des inscrits et des exprimés
aux élections municipales chiffres
ministère de l'intérieur et selon les
mêmes chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur il fait trois et demi pour
cent aux élections et des inscrits aux
sélections régionales donc il n'a rien à
perdre
à avoir une politique de dureté casanova
je me casse taxant qui ont apprécié sa
pensée 2000 euros à cette fameuse
indemnité inflation de 100 euros qui
sera donc versé à ces français qui
gagnent moins de 1000 euros il dit en
gros c'est le salaire médian des
français 36 millions de français
concernés c'est une
justement vous jérôme rodriguez sachant
qu'avec 100 euros c'est vrai que ça va
être compliqué de pallier à toute cette
somme est ce que cette somme va la
destination des ménages pour pau
milliers aussi les catégories
professionnelles là je viens de discuter
avec un taxi qui sont fortement aussi
impacté par l'augmentation du gazoil
tous les tranches de métier qui
utilisent nos véhicules sont passés en
passant par les ambulanciers ou autre
mais sont heureux
on est là on va faire du blabla pendant
une semaine on va vous parler de
pourcentage de ceux ci c'est simple 780
euros d'augmentation du budget carburant
à la fin de l'année pour une voiture
pour lequel vous ferez un plein de 50
litres par semaine on est à 780 euros il
nous lâche son euro mais encore faut
encore aller les chercher je pense
j'imagine qu'il faut remplir tout un tas
de conditions donc ça reste sans vous je
ne sais pas ce qu'il aurait été plus
juste il est clair qu'aujourd'hui le
compte n'y est pas on pourra nous dire
oui 36 millions multiplié par 100 ça
fait tant de gros matches le compte n'y
est pas
100 euros ça va faire quoi ça va faire
deux pleins on en est à il nous manque
encore 50 plein pour que les gens
puissent aller travailler en et leur
gamin à l'école faire des courses quand
vous vivez en province vous faites 20 km
pour les chercher un billet de 20 euros
vous faites 24 km pour les mettre votre
plein d'essence vous arrivez vous n'avez
plus que 10 euros hors taxes
c'est ça c'est du concret aujourd'hui
faut arrêter de parler en pourcentage en
bla bla on parle euros aujourd'hui on
parle poche des français qui
malheureusement on n'a plus aujourd'hui
c'est plus le 15 du mois quand quand les
légendes sont sortis aujourd'hui ça va
être le 10 du mois voir le 8 du mois et
ça c'est plus possible
jérôme brodier en veux remercier parce
que vous avez de voir filer
malheureusement en tout cas merci
d'avoir réagi à ces annonces de jean
castex le monde fin pour vous je
casanova c'est justement cette crainte 1
de ce mouvement quand on écoute géré le
jérôme rodriguez on se dit que c'est
quelque chose vraiment qui risque de se
reproduire ce mouvement aussi bien dans
la rue et évidemment sur la question que
vous posez tout à l'heure dans les urnes
parce que le compte ne semble pas y être
en tout cas la mesure présentée est une
mesure technocratique qui va vers
l'échec son volume n'est pas à la
hauteur des problèmes et en tant qu elle
coûte cher il y avait une autre méthode
très simple qui était une échelle mobile
des taxes qui fasse que le prix des
carburants reste le même à la pour le
consommateur la part des taxes diminuant
d'autant que aux montres et le prix du
carburant lui même c'est une méthode qui
a été mis en place il ya quelques années
qui est évidemment coûteuse tout est
coûteux mais au moins elle al'avantage
que le consommateur final à un prix qui
ne bouge pas mais pour des raisons
idéologiques liée à la force de
l'idéologie
écologiste n'est pas les partis
écologistes mais une idéologie que le
gist qui touche très spécifiquement
l'électorat du président et du
gouvernement actuel il y à un refus de
cette solution qui ferait simple alors
tournoi ce que ça peut être une vraie
erreur politique avant de commettre un
gouvernement macron ce soir
c'est possible mais il a déjà fait
tellement de choses maladroite qu'on a
l'impression que d'un certain point de
vue la coupe est déjà pleine elle
déborde merci beaucoup en tout cas vous
gêne casanova également merci à jérôme
brielles ce qui vient de nous quitter
pour un autre plateau télé voilà en tout